I'm here with Anna
aka Starfire so I watched the first two
episodes I got it and I got to say you
were the best character you're the
breakout star I enjoyed your character
so much and and so I don't know if
you've seen on social media but every
yeah it's just everybody's definitive
everybody saying they love you so I just
wanted to let you know that but how was
it just playing this iconic character
like when you first found out you were
Starfire what was it like you know I
wasn't super familiar with the comics
when I first got the ro but as soon as I
did I went to the store I got all the
girl who looks like hood I just did
everything I could do and then I kind of
listened to people like I went online
and I read what people people really
they really connect to these characters
and it's something that really means a
lot to people and so I really wanted to
get it right because of that so I felt a
lot of responsibility and yeah and then
I just had to find you and it did turn
out great so out of all the episodes so
far we shot what was your favorite
episode I'm okay so I always like shoes
the episode that I meet in the lease cuz
that's the one I can watch and like not
be stressed about but it also happens to
be honestly like such a dope episode and
it's five and it's the dude patrol
episode oh my god that episode is so
crazy so if you could like like we have
Doom Patrol we have all these other DC
shows coming around would you like to
make any guest appearance or cameo on
there I would love to do patrol left off
we have fantastic shows so yeah
absolutely
make it happen DC get star fire
everywhere pineapples on pizza how do
you feel about that I'm with I'm with
Raven I'm thank you thank you so much
Starfire and Raven have sense Beast Boy
Ryan yes
pineapples yes
not together cut it out and so over over
the course of the show we know we are
introduced to dig we see that
relationship start to grow as a season
progresses yeah and it really evolves I
mean it kind of begins as one thing and
evolves into something else and yeah
it's good Princeton's amazing and if you
could be anybody else on the cast has
anybody else's origin story or powers
who would you pick these were so happy
and and awesome I would probably be able
take yeah thank you so much for talking
with us
I know want to say again she crushes
that Starfire she really is amazing
thank you for everything